this video is sponsored by squarespace
the best way to make an amazing website
it's been a week since i switched to the
iphone 12 pro after using the 11 pro for
over a year
and today i'm going to tell you every
real world difference i noticed
some that apple advertised and i was
expecting in a bunch that for some
reason they didn't
but were really nice and even a few
disappointments there's even one
improvement that blew my mind so much
that if apple didn't change
anything but this i would still upgrade
in a heartbeat
and no it's not the cameras or the new
design let's skip the specs since you've
heard them a hundred times already and
jump
right in starting with one headline
grabbing downgrade
and that's the lack of a charging brick
the eleven pro was the first iphone to
come with one
but it didn't need it the battery life
was amazing
but this year unfortunately it's
noticeably worse which i'll talk about
in just a bit now they did drop the
price of their new 20 watt usb-c
fast charger from 29 dollars to 19 and i
got a few to get the fastest charging
speed
but when i tested it with the 12 pro it
wouldn't charge
any faster than 18 watts anyway my 11
pro max on the other hand
would charge at the full 20 watt now
maybe it's just mine
or maybe only the max models with the
bigger batteries can make use of the
fastest chargers
if you have older 18 watt chargers just
use one of those
and if you don't buy an anchor fast
charger instead
they are much smaller and they're just
as fast
in fact they're actually faster for
magsafe charging
and the 18 watt is only slightly slower
than apple's 20 watt
i'm working on an ultimate iphone 12
charger comparison
and there's a few surprises so make sure
you're subscribed if you want to see it
as for the max safe charger
i was initially excited for it but
that's worn off
now yes it is slightly faster to connect
than using a lightning cable
and it's always aligned perfectly but it
takes about twice as long to charge the
phone from zero to a hundred percent now
once we get some other mac safe
accessories
maybe car mounts and other things i may
start to get excited again now you may
have noticed that i moved from an 11 pro
max
and man do i love this size in my iphone
11 review i said that the 5.8 inch pro
is too small
the six and a half inch max is too big
and 6.1 is the perfect size
but i didn't want the lcd or having dual
cameras instead of three of them and if
they made the pro
6.1 inches i would switch so did i miss
the bigger
screen no not really after the first few
hours i got used to it
and when i go back to holding the max it
is massive
and way less comfortable even for my
bigger hands now part of that
is because of the old but new design i
do have a 10s and even though the 12 pro
has a bigger screen
it's the same width and only slightly
taller due to the new slim bezels
so for those of you that have a smaller
iphone size won't be an issue with this
one
and i have to say that the square edges
are much more secure in your hand
now a few times this week i did notice
that the square edges dug into my hand
if i use the phone for a long time
so if you text for hours you might want
to get a case
i'll go and link a couple suggested ones
down below and no i don't
really suggest this one from apple
another thing is that the 12's new
strong ceramic screen
seems to scratch easier i have been
super careful but i already have a few
scratches
so you might want to use a screen
protector i'll link that a few cases and
this tiny anchor 20 watt charger down in
the video description
now unfortunately apple pulled a samsung
and is now putting the best cameras in
their largest phone
the 12 pro max and of course i'm going
to buy one and test it for you now i
don't want to but i might end up
switching and dealing with a huge size
if the camera difference is noticeable
along with battery life now before i
cover that
in the shockingly better 5g and lte
speeds
let me give a shout out to our sponsor
squarespace if you've been thinking
about making your own website
squarespace is seriously the best way to
go
we've built multiple websites and you
can too with literally no web making
experience
you just choose a template customize
blocks of text and images and easily
move them around it's incredibly simple
it's affordable and ours have been
running flawlessly for years now
bringing in new clients thanks to its
built-in seo tools so whether you're
making a website for a small business or
for
literally anything else go to
squarespace.commaxtech for a free no
credit card required trial
and use our coupon code when you're
ready to check out to save 10 off your
first purchase of a website or domain
now let's talk about battery life and it
has been
disappointing the 11 pro's battery life
must have been my favorite upgrade from
the 10s max and instead of needing to
charge at six or seven each evening
at bedtime i still had about 20 battery
remaining
well all of that went down the drain and
now i'm right back to having a top off
each day
at around six o'clock now yes this thing
has a much smaller battery than the 11
pro max
and even smaller than the 11 pro even
though it's
bigger it does have a more efficient
five nanometer processor
but at the same time we have a larger
display mr who's the boss
tested it and got one hour less battery
life than the 11 pro
but that was without 5g enabled and when
it's on
tests have shown that you'll lose about
another hour of battery life
getting you back to iphone 10s levels
now thankfully a lot of people won't
need to if they want to save battery
life because a normal 4g
lte is wicked fast i tested it in a
snowstorm and the difference was
insane the 12 pro got 32 download
instead of 4
even though the 12 showed one less bar
of reception
and going outside of my concrete office
i got four times faster download
and twice the upload speed and remember
this is
only 4g now how is this possible well
since the iphone 7 apple started to
switch to intel modems
and as you can see they're not only
behind in cpus with the iphone 12 we're
finally back to qualcomm modems thanks
to 5g
and both the 12 and the 12 pro use the
x55
the very best one currently on the
market speaking of 5g here in spokane we
only have the slowest
which is low band but that's the case in
most cities
even still it's noticeably faster than
the 4g i get
during that snowstorm the 12 pro went
from 22 download up to 45
and let's just say that over the last
week i have noticed a dramatic
difference in both coverage
and speeds with the 11 pro i complained
that even 720p
video would buffer at times but now most
of the time i can actually stream
4k and i have reception in a few
previous dead spots
and if you're somebody that tethers to
their laptop like i do
the speed difference is huge thanks to
the newer modem and 5 gigahertz
tethering instead of 2.4 gigahertz
going from 3 megabit per second download
and less than one upload all the way to
36 down and 18
up just make sure that maximize
compatibility is turned off in your
tethering settings
let me just say that if apple did
nothing else to the 11 pro
but upgrade the modem and call it the 12
i would still upgrade in a heartbeat
because real world differences is that
big for me now if you want to know more
about this i'm working on a video
testing the 5g and 4g
differences all around town at different
parts of the day
and this time without the snowstorm so
make sure to enable those notifications
if you guys want to see that
now another big frustration was
background apps
i'm a power user and the iphone 11 pro
regularly closed large apps that i was
using
especially if i open the camera app i
always envy the androids with their 12
gigs of ram
where i could reopen apps from the day
before and they were still
saved thankfully the 12 pro has 6 gigs
of ram instead of the iphone 11 pros
4 gigs so i'm happy to let you know that
i didn't notice this happen
even once in the last week hopefully
apple will keep ios 14
updates well optimized so it stays this
way now let's touch on speakers
apple didn't mention them but there's
definitely a noticeable difference
take a listen for yourself
[Music]
is
[Music]
i found that the mids and bass are a
little bit more rich but would i notice
that if i wasn't comparing them side by
side
no what i would notice though is the
high frequencies which are louder and
more crisp
because of this the speakers peak two
decibels louder and i
love that at least most of the time most
music and videos
sound great but every once in a while
certain songs and voices
make it sound too sharp with that said i
would gladly take the trade off for
better sounding
louder speakers 95 of the time and
finally
on to the cameras overall it's a decent
update but i thought it would be bigger
now don't get me wrong
there's some instances where the
difference is massive but other times
the 12 pro is the same
or maybe even worse now if i covered all
of these in this video it would be more
than twice as long
so if you want to see every little
difference click right over there to
watch my ultimate camera comparison
against the 11 pro
and even the 10s max click above if you
guys want to subscribe so you guys don't
miss out more videos like this one
and if you haven't seen it yet check out
vadim's review as well
this has been max and i will see you in
the next video
[Music]